what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
for Star Wars Jedi Survivor and today
I'm joined by my great friend Michael
the Tesla from multi-house.io that's it
yeah go check it out I've done stuff
with them I'm gonna continue to do stuff
with them he's like one of the biggest
Star Wars nerds I know I mean look at
him oh God we got a real nerd oh you're
in so much trouble Greg you're a big fan
of the first game it like got me through
the pandemic I might have cried a little
bit during the first trailer so I'm
excited for this all right do you think
they should leave a like if you don't
like And subscribe uh I don't know what
you're doing you're missing out on some
real sexy Greg content do you ever feel
like at night you need a little bit more
energy I mean that's why I watch real
reason I'm about to do a shout out
today guys I'm gonna literally have G
fuel at my wedding and if you know me I
always offered G fuel to everyone who
comes into my household because I
absolutely love it you know what here
I'm just gonna I'm gonna just take you
guys on a quick journey in my kitchen to
show you how much you feel I have just
so you know it's in real look look we're
right here here's us now we're gonna go
to the kitchen
[Music]
look at all this G fuel so much G fuel
everywhere oh my God
I think like with just the amount of
hours that uh we can often spend
especially since we're trying to get a
week ahead on the channel oftentimes you
need something that helps you with
keeping your energy up and focus and to
not also crash special code in the
description box you guys can use all
right guys let's watch this
[Music]
view order is gone
I was betrayed
by the one I trusted most
who is this yeah yeah I will not be
imprisoned again
oh [ __ ] oh man
damn
I hear you've been busy making yourself
the Empire's Most Wanted
oh my God
friend
remind our friend here why is God
supposed to be dead
dual wielding Jesus Christ Arch okay
look at that it was only grown stronger
oh man
[Music]
this guy
where are they part of the joke oh my
God he's got himself in front
oh look at this
oh my god
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
I cannot get over this
survives
[Music]
previous destroys
ah yeah you just saw in the the
background they had the the CIS
oh my God I was wanting them to show
them using the the Blaster oh I wanted
to see you I wanted to see you it was
like wait a minute
dude that was uh I'm like that was that
was a big freaking trailer right there
yeah there's there's like a lot to
unpack yeah that was uh wow that was a
beautiful ass trailer the dual wielding
and there are parts of this that remind
me you played a force unleashed oh dude
that's exactly uh like I hope Cal's not
too Opie
yeah the fleshing out of the
environments the way they utilize
everything like it just feels like such
a massive upgrade because this really
does feel like you're a Jedi being
brought to life even though it was
mainly gameplay they do tease some story
elements so this is the second time
they're teasing that person the back the
tank do you have any idea who this
villain might be or any Theory so so I
have faith in our Lord and savior is
Dave filoni and John Favreau that there
is a master plan going on right now that
incorporates this that incorporates this
Rebels that incorporates Ahsoka
Mandalorian book of boba and a lot of it
comes down to this cloning facility was
teased in bad batch and that
definitively is like where like
Palpatine's son and like all the Snokes
were made this comes from a Legend's uh
storyline that like I loved as a kid
where there was this like Jedi
supremacist like from way back in the
day who is like Jedi or bust but like
took it a little too far based on what
we saw I think that my might be him or
at least an inspiration or some
iteration it makes sense like where we
leave Cal off is like you know he wanted
to rebuild the Jedi Order and all the
grand Masters are gone he had to destroy
you know the the list of all the young
ones the holocrons leaves us in this
like really interesting spot where if
you're looking for help and there's like
rumor of like an all-powerful Jedi that
could take on the emperor and it turns
out when you let him go he's maybe not
the guy
I love the the tease of him because like
Trilla third sister was a wonderfully
nuanced antagonist in that game kind of
get the impression here there'll be a
similar thing where there'll be a lot of
pathos to this character where it'll
could have a similar effect where you're
like all right he was menacing when we
first met him but I kind of get where
he's coming from
or they might just double down and make
him like extra evil or some [ __ ] like
that I wonder how long this I didn't
read much about what this game is
supposed to be about so I wonder how
long the separation is yeah it's I think
it's been like five years or so
she made some comment there about like
here you've been kicking ass or
something and that seemed like
particularly seeing her again number one
like her look was awesome it's nice to
see her a little bit more Regal yeah
like at peace with her and like the
force it was particularly neat seeing
the Jedi archives uh which is something
like like they've teased it in some of
the Canon literature but they haven't
showed it yet but like the grand
librarian of the Jedi survives Order 66
tries to preserve a lot of that
knowledge and I love the idea of getting
to see her again
at least in some kind of something
um I'm not gonna spoil what happens to
her but first person I know to ever
tease the librarian for there it's dude
she was she was my first love you know
some people are into like lay in a
bikini me it was
well I'm into this uh new uh scoundrel
solo replacement yeah
the team enough together looks cool find
yourself a friend that you know you can
jump over like that
I think the last thing uh you you said
Knights of REM but I thought the Knights
of Ren came after yeah
so so that's a common kind of
misconception so like a bunch of dumb
asses out there so there's a compliment
conception about no so when Ben solo
okay kylo is uh training at the Jedi
Temple the Knights of Ren were like out
and about they were already a thing and
um he ended up grouping up with them and
uh the kicking the leader's ass and
killing him and the leader was like a
super badass guy if it kind of reminds
me of this fella based on like the
canonical description of him the other
direction that this maybe could go just
like based on on that jet pack yeah is
you know this is when the the siege of
Mandalore around the time that that
happens
yeah you know and and so he could very
much be be Death Watch or you know one
of the he kind of has like that Vibe of
like the armorer from the Mandalorian I
feel like the Knights of Ren were one of
those things that they just like screwed
the pooch on like totally they looked
awesome we don't know what you know we
don't know anything
so you know it would be really cool to
be able to to see them kind of go
backwards and and tell the story that
probably would have given some cool
contact especially if that's like an OP
villain that you can't beat
um but the only one that did was kylo
hey a Boy Can Dream I like his
lightsaber a lot that's me that's my
commentary yeah I mean it's it's it's
cool I mean I always something I loved
about Cal's character is like
little Flames
I have the greatest lights he has a
little homage to to his master in there
and it's been five years later like
clearly he's not a Padawan anymore
um so it's gonna be exciting to see him
kind of step into his step into his own
I mean it looks like the game is
starting off or he's in his own room
this was the the the lightsaber from the
Old Republic
um like last time we saw that uh was
like
it was it was right when uh Vader and
Ahsoka had their um Rebel rematch uh but
you know the long anticipating reunion
um and yeah as Ezra finds that at the
scene of a battlefield between the
ancient Jedi and the ancient Sith and so
like if I'm going to get like a little
conspiracy theory here for a second you
have this Old Republic element that
they're clearly pushing you have this
like Legends character that could very
well be inspired by this like sure I
don't know I get a lot of like Knights
of the Old Republic Vibes dude I'm glad
you were here you actually had a lot to
say
it's not all going to be in the video
guys oh that's okay but when we do the
shows you're gonna have a lot to say oh
it's it's it's going to be a blast you
did great Michael great great first
video it's not easy being here
it's not it's not easy being green I
often uh make people feel very tense and
uncomfortable in their first videos and
you overcame the challenge no I'm just
intense and uncomfortable and naturally
so it's a you know well I love it I
loved your working Moneyball and Wolf of
Wall Street and
[Laughter]
yeah guys well what'd you think of the
trailer your thoughts down below
subscribe leave a like follow Michael
and whatever the link is in the
description box and I follow him on the
Mt Tesla MJ Tesla and May the force be
with you May the force be with all of
you you sons of [ __ ]
[Music]